hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here from
anime uproar and in this video i will be
breaking down
everything we know so far about every
notable devil
in the black clover story from zagred
the main villain of the elf saga to
osta's own
devil bro and of course the overpowered
devil villains of the spade kingdom war
arc
we're gonna be talking about all of them
right here
the devils are some of the strongest and
most fascinating beings in the entire
world of black clover
so let's get into it if you enjoy our
black clover videos and you want to show
your support
just leave a like and comment it's a
quick and completely free way to support
the channel
right now and of course if you want to
keep seeing our videos in the future
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says
all if you don't do that you're gonna
miss a ton of our videos
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar finally this
video will contain
black clover manga spoilers i will be
using
all of the available information on the
devils so please proceed with caution
you have been warned let's start it off
with zagred
the main villain of the elf saga and the
first devil that we meet
in the proper sense of the word i mean
we've technically known asta's devil
longer
but we didn't get to see his true form
and we didn't really learn anything
about him until much later in the story
zagred is a male devil who has been
alive for over 500 years
and who is known as being one of the
highest ranking devils in the devil
hierarchy
this means that he is incredibly
powerful and has an impressive amount of
mana even by the standards of the
underworld
zagred was of course the mastermind
behind the elf
massacre and he is secretly responsible
for pretty much all the terrible things
that happened
during the elf saga right before the elf
massacre
zagred possessed one of the clover
kingdom's royal ministers
and he manipulated the humans of the
clover kingdom and convinced them to
betray the elves and attack them during
leaked
and tethya's wedding ceremony nearly the
entire elf tribe was wiped out
tethya was seriously injured and leaked
descended into despair
which turned his grimoire into a
five-leaf grimoire
zagred then attempted to take possession
of leaked's powerful mana rich body
but leaked refused to let that happen
with the help of the magic stones
he transformed himself into the giant
demon
which effectively stopped zagred from
being able to possess him
zagred then tried to take possession of
leaked five-leaf grimoire but secret was
able to use her sealing magic
and the magic stones to seal zagret away
in an eternal prison
however before the seal could be
completed zagred managed to summon the
magic stones
and he then used them to ensure that the
souls of the massacred elves will be
reincarnated in the future
along with him this reincarnation occurs
some five centuries later
and zagred eventually manipulates poetry
and the other reincarnated elves into
opening the shadow palace
zagret is then able to summon his
original body from the underworld
and this sets the stage for the final
epic battle
of the elf saga zagred uses kotodama
magic which is a type of magic that
allows him to alter
physical reality with his words he can
summon monsters
swords and all sorts of other magical
and non-magical weapons by just
mentioning them verbally
and he can also manipulate a wide
variety of objects and living beings
at will most magic from the human world
has little to no effect on zagred
the only exceptions are yami's dark
magic
and osta's anti-magic zagred
is eventually defeated by a massive team
effort that includes not only asta and
yami
but a bunch of other overpowered
warriors including the first wizard king
and leaked that was truly an epic
showdown and one of my personal favorite
shonen fights of
all time okay now let's talk about
asta's devil
liebe who also turned out to be asta's
adoptive brother
liebe was born inside the underworld as
one of the lowest
ranked devils in fact when he was born
he had
no magic at all which is an extremely
rare
occurrence because of his weakness and
lack of magic
liebe was constantly abused and bullied
by the other devils
and one day he was thrown into the gate
that separates the underworld from the
human world
the devil who threw liebe was expecting
him to smash
into the gate and die but instead leiber
passed through the gate and ended up
in the human world it seems that the
gate was designed to stop
any being with magic from passing
through it
but because liebe had no magic he was
able to pass
through after everything that he had
been through liebe had no desire to
attack humans or to try to manipulate
them in any way
but because he is a devil and of course
he looks like a devil
the humans who came across him were
scared of him they assumed that because
he is a devil he must be evil and
dangerous
and so they summoned the magic knights
to get rid of him
liebe is forced to run from the magic
knights and he eventually collapses
somewhere deep in the woods but instead
of being killed by the humans
as he was fully expecting liebe wakes up
to find that he has been taken in
by a human woman named lychita and this
woman has been taking care of him and
nursing him back to health
lichita eventually decides to adopt
liebe and to raise him as her
own son it turns out that lychita is
also an outcast from society
just like liebe her body steals magic
and life force from everything around
her including all
living creatures she doesn't seem to
have the power to turn this
ability off so she is shunned by society
since no one wants to have their life
force or magic drained
however since liba has no magic and
since he is a devil rather than a human
he is able to live with lychita without
suffering any negative consequences
as time passes lichita and liba become
like
mother and son it is truly a
heartwarming relationship
and we eventually learned that lichita
was forced to give up
one child in the past presumably to
protect the child from being negatively
affected by her
magic and as it turns out that
child was none other than asta
himself so liebe asta's devil
was actually raised by osta's own birth
mother
everything is going great until one day
lucifer
one of the highest ranked devils
discovers that liebe
is able to live inside the human world
without a human
host lucifer then attempts to take over
libya's body
but lychita loves libya as her own son
so when lucifer tries to possess him
she sacrifices herself in order to save
him
legita fights back against lucifer and
she manages to force him
out of libya's body by using her magic
to absorb a portion
of lucifer's mana unfortunately before
lucifer disappears
he manages to give lychita a fatal
injury
believing that her time is running out
ligita uses her
other ability which is the ability to
seal anything without magic
inside an inanimate object to seal liba
himself
inside a five-leaf grimoire that she had
found at some point
in the past and that grimoire is of
course leaked
former grimoire that is how liba ended
up
inside that five-leaf grimoire where he
was safe
from future attacks by lucifer and as he
spent many years
inside the grimoire liba grew older
and stronger and he also spent pretty
much all of his time
plotting revenge against lucifer and the
other devils for destroying his life and
killing his mother
at some point while inside the grimoire
liba's anti-magic abilities began to
manifest
this might have been a latent ability
that he was always going to manifest
or it might have been the result of
lychita's absorption magic
or some combination of the two for
example
maybe lichita accidentally sealed away
some of her own absorption magic
and maybe even some of lucifer's magic
along with liba
inside the grimoire and then the
combination
of absorption magic and lucifer's devil
magic inside the grimoire
eventually created what we know today as
anti-magic after the five-leaf grimoire
chooses
osta as its new owner liba's initial
plan was to take over asta's body and
just use
asta as a tool to get his revenge but
eventually
asta and liba decide to work together
because liba realizes that
asta is not his rival he is actually his
long-lost adoptive brother and the two
of them share a common enemy
lucifer and speaking of lucifer let's
talk about him
next because he plays such a prominent
role in the entire spade kingdom war arc
lucifer also known as lucifero is one of
the highest ranking devils who resides
at the very lowest level of the
underworld
and therefore at the bottom of the tree
of clifforth
at some point in the past lucifer made a
contract with a human host by the name
of dante
zogradus who is of course one of the
members of the dark
triad all three zogradus siblings are
devil magic users
and they used their magic powers to
overthrow the ruling house of the spade
kingdom
and take control for themselves lucifer
uses immensely powerful gravity magic
which as the name suggests allows its
user to manipulate gravity
in various ways in chapter 286 it is
stated that the underworld is actually
ruled by three devils
one has time magic one has spatial magic
and one has gravity magic which suggests
that lucifer
is likely one of the three rulers of the
underworld
and since i just mentioned spatial magic
let's talk about xenon's devil
now we still don't know this devil's
name but we know that its magic allows
it to manipulate the fabric
of space itself xenon's devil
is one of the highest ranking devils so
he could be one of the three rulers of
the underworld
based on the information we got in
chapter 286
about one of them having spatial magic
xenon's devil makes its host incredibly
strong
and xenon has demonstrated his strength
over and over again
including in his fight against the
entire diamond kingdom army
in his fight against william vongenz and
the golden dawn
and in his ability to rescue dante and
kidnap yami at the same time
using his devil's spatial magic the
third devil associated with the dark
triad
is vanica's devil megikula megikula
also appears to be one of the highest
ranking devils and this devil possesses
tremendously powerful curse magic this
suggests that megicula
is not one of the three rulers of the
underworld because she doesn't have any
of the three magical attributes that the
rulers of the underworld
are said to have that said mekikula has
been around for a long time
and all curse magic in the human world
is said to have come
from her in the past she apparently made
a pact with members of the agrippa
family
and she also personally cursed noel's
mother aussie
silva and princess loro pachika
makikula's curse magic is so powerful
that it can take down
arcane stage mages and it can even have
an effect on
elemental spirits megicula is said to be
considerably stronger than zagred
and to be fair her gender is not
actually known at this time
i usually refer to her as she because i
associate her with
vanica that said the devils do appear to
have genders
since a couple of devils that we've met
possess distinctly feminine features
like breasts and one of these devils is
lilith
so let's talk about her and nama lilith
and the ma
appear to be twins and they are both
released into the human world from the
top level
of the tree of clifforth lilith
possesses
devil ice magic and namah possesses
devil fire magic but these are not
normal forms of fire and ice magic
rather
they are special and overpowered devil
versions
of these magic attributes and this means
that they are able to freeze
and burn everything not only can they
burn and freeze physical
matter but they can also burn and freeze
things without a physical substance
such as light shadows and darkness
lilith and amma both appear to be
complete psychos who love
toying with weaker creatures including
humans
they entertain themselves by
overpowering and tormenting
other life forms there is a fan theory
out there somewhere that one of these
two devils
was the devil who threw liebe up into
the human world
alright now let's talk about the four
different devils who made a contract
with
noct the vice captain of the black
bulls all four of these devils are
mid-ranked devils
which means that they are not among the
weakest devils but they are also nowhere
near the highest ranked devils when it
comes to power
as the heir to the noble faust family
which had been secretly studying devils
and forbidden magic for generations
noct was able to gain access to these
four devils
at a very young age and due to his
exceptional talent for devil magic
he was able to make contracts with all
four of them
each devil has a chibi form as a devil
familiar
and a larger form which is based on an
animal first up we have guimodello
whose appearance is based on a dog and
whose unite mode with knocked is called
connis when in conus mode noct can use
an ability called
pack which allows him to basically
generate a bunch of shadow
clones then we have slottos whose
appearance is based on a horse
and whose unite mode with knocked is
called equus
this mode functions like a powerful
shadow armor that makes
knocked a lot tougher and more resilient
so
it is an excellent defensive technique
next up we have plumade
whose appearance is based on a cat and
whose unite mode with knocked is called
felis this mode allows noct to use
incredible speed and agility to run
circles
around his opponents finally we have
wahlgren
whose appearance is based on a rooster
and whose unite mode with knocked is
called
galus this mode allows noct to unleash a
loud cry that has the power to paralyze
his opponents
it is important to note that these devil
unite forms may still have
other abilities and techniques that we
just haven't seen yet
it is also important to note that noct
has the ability to unite with more than
one of his devils
at the same time in chapter 287
noct is able to unite with both plumede
and waldner to create a special devil
union form called
galos x feliz at first noct believes
that uniting with two
mid-ranked devils will make him strong
enough to rival a
highest ranked devil but unfortunately
for knocked
this does not turn out to be the case
the final devil that we need to talk
about here is
lucy fugus lucy fugus is one of the
highest ranked devils
and noct actually tried to summon him
back when he was younger
in an attempt to make him the fifth
devil that he could make a contract
with the faust family orchestrated an
elaborate secret ritual
in order to summon lucy fugus but
this devil was so strong that he ended
up killing everyone inside the building
except for knocked himself in fact
noct's twin brother morgan sacrificed
his own life
in order to stop the ritual and save
knocked
in chapter 286 of the manga it is
implied that lucy fubus
serves directly under the three rulers
of the underworld
so he is presumably not one of those
three
his magic attribute and other details
are still unknown
as of the making of this video
and that is it every notable devil in
black clover
explained there are of course many other
less significant
low tier and mid-tier devils that we met
during the spade kingdom war arc
basically nameless devil npcs
but we know so little about them that it
really doesn't make sense to mention
them specifically
let me know what you guys think about
the devils in black clover
and who is your favorite devil so far
also who is this devil who uses time
magic
and will anybody be able to stop a
highest ranked
devil with the power to control time
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more blacklover content
here on the channel please leave that
like to let me know it really does help
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at anime uproar a big thank you to all
of our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
acquired respect
pate heffa liam thompson algertol dr
cortman
dustin scarlett emperor talk who's
spidey life chanel
big buddhist tungsten tarkis and yuno
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp rathune de ora very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks hinokamian
water joanne garcia
the red-haired raven ted no ted
isparky65
fatboy games deadly saint and soul race
slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you